Thank You Yaya it's a great pleasure to
be here and actually my first time at
Yale so interesting on many accounts I'm
as you might have noticed from the title
somehow my background looks a bit
different in the sense that I'm going to
try to talk to you about trying to
explain to you why what people like
Scott Sheffield myself or the tram
number of people in sort of have been
doing on random two-dimensional systems
is very much related with the are false
bears legacy type mathematics and why
maybe this your community should you
know be interested in that trying to
convince you about these things of
course probably several of you or most
of you have heard you know talks about
this general story before by other
people but how nevertheless when I was
preparing the this lecture I figured
that probably the most useful was still
you know not to dive into the very
recent the most recent things but rather
to try to give you a general picture of
presentation of one aspect of this that
can be you know be presented in the
self-contained way and because you're
mathematicians you will not be
interested or particularly
sort of motivated by maybe the physical
background why physicists have been
interested in that and why you know in
some sense we are more interested in
concrete things about conformal
transformations rather than you know
abstract physical field theories but I'm
maybe I can just say that the story I'm
going to tell has I mean there are
motivations for this coming from physics
both from sort of fairly concrete
physics like you know you take some
model and then you see these random
structures emerging in almost real real
life or in a very sort of meta
theoretical approach to physics and in a
way it's the same one that sort of you
know motivated riemann in some sense
which is having to say that i've just
you know give you just a little seed you
know i'm doing the usual thing i tell
you i'm not going to tell you about it
but then after all it's just tell you
about it which is that in the same way
in some sense you know you know newton's
gravitation and is related to harmonic
functions and harmonic functions are
related you know laplacian and complex
analysis comes you know on the backpack
you could say you know you could just
say well you know what are the natural
fluctuations away from harmonic
functions what would be the natural
oscillation away from harmonic functions
or what would be the natural way to
fluctuations away from euclidean
distance in space right and in some
sense these type of structures that when
you try to understand them then you and
very quickly in into the the topics i'm
going to tell you about now let's try to
be concrete and let me try to present to
you sort of the the main couple of the
main players objects in our
in this story so we're looking for
random compact connected subsets of the
disk right so in some sense we want to
define measures
I mean probability measures on things
that are familiar to us and the idea
would be you know we want to find random
pictures you can draw a subsets of the
unit disk and we're going to give
ourself certain rules and the first rule
would be that the distribution the law
of this picture is invariant under any
Mobius transformation of the disk so you
fix yourself you know any Mobius
transformation here you have some random
picture right and you transform it by
your fixed Mobius transformation once
you want that the distribution of the
image that you have here is the same
distribution as the one you started with
okay so it's not very difficult to find
you know some random pictures that you
can draw and that arc informally you
know invariant sort of the simplest
would be you know you you fix just you
know you fix some conformal triangle I
mean you just define a random conformal
triangle that contains the origin using
some you know the and then you just
reflect this infinitely many times and
then you get a random picture and if you
just you know choose this picture to
somehow to be translation invariant in
the hyperbolic space then you get one
random picture that is conformally
invariant so it's it's very easy to you
know find a random picture that is
actually invariant under idea maybe it's
transformation that's a piece of cake so
that's not all we want to do but however
I want to note that when we when you
have a random picture sub picture in the
in the in the unit disk that is actually
invariant under any Mobius
transformation then you can actually
define it also you take any simply
connected domain
and you can say what's the distribute
what's the law of the random picture
that you would draw in this simply
connected domain well then you just say
well I choose any conformal
transformation from the unit disk into
that domain I have my picture here right
that I ran a picture that I did draw
before I transform it by my fixed
conformal transformation here and I have
a random picture here and and this is
the distribution what we would call of
the random picture in this new domain
that you have there okay okay that's
fine we still have many possibilities to
do this and now comes the sort of the
the real important condition we want to
put on our random picture and this will
have to do with you know here comes live
now somehow but into the picture but the
idea is you want to look at you think of
your picture as a bit like a random
sponge right so these are holes okay and
the object you have the structure you
are interested in somehow the this
sponge here right and the idea will be
the condition you want to put is the
following is that if you take scissors
any you know you take your pair of
scissors and you cut this open so you
cut it into two pieces like this well
then this you know the sponge falls into
you know service decompose into several
pieces actually you could have more than
two pieces are because you know you
might have you know hole a hole that was
doing this and therefore here you have a
third piece you know so you have the
sponge is sort of divided into several
pieces and then the conditioner is like
when you were a child and you were
cutting well I don't know if you were
one of these nasty childs but you are
cutting a little warms that you were
finding in the in the in the ground and
you cut it and then well the little
piece you get is again a warm right it's
actually continues to
you live you know its own life and it's
sort of self similar to the initial one
you started with and so the condition
here is the following I have my random
picture you take this orange scissors
you you cut it into pieces and now you
have several pieces and you look at them
so say you take this one right so it
looks like you have this random sponge
it has this sort of picture like yeah
and so now what you do is you you know
you say okay let's use Ramon's mapping
theorem and map the outside right back
to the unit disk right so Yuri stretch
this in order for this to be back in the
unit disk and you get now a random
picture you start with this random
picture here you cut it you just take
you know one piece of one of the pieces
and you look at it stretch it back and
now the condition that we want is that
this random picture you get there is the
same as the one you started with it's
not the same picture right it's the
distribution of the picture so the idea
is to say well I have one experiment is
I look at the picture I have it just I
start with this is one random experiment
and have around another random
experiment which consists of not looking
at the picture cut it true just take one
piece of your sponge expand it back and
now I have another picture and think
this the distribution of these two
random pictures are the same okay this
looks like quite a you know simple rules
right so we want to understand well
first do such objects like that exist at
all
question number one if so yeah if so yes
and what can we say about them so if you
think about it it's a little bit like
you know you want to find random
structures define any unit disk that you
know have conformer invariants built-in
but also the the way the conformance
variances
since sort of you know there's an
interplay between the structure here the
location of the holes and what you mean
by conform when variants then after
after now you you know you see so what
the the collection of you know when a
random collection a random set like that
satisfies these property we like to call
it conformal loop ensemble CL II that's
because one talks about the loops here
the holes and not about the object but
in the rest of the talk I'm going to say
a random sponge okay so that you haven't
cured you know that you see that we
focus on the actual set that we have
here so you can think about it a little
bit you first realize well of course if
you have if you want this picture to be
invariant under you know Mobius
transformation should have some sort of
hyperbolic structure there will be
infinitely many holes right will not be
possible to have just one or two or
three holes in there because the holes
will you have plenty of holes near the
net you know the boundary that's one
first remark and the other remark would
be if you think about what's the
probability that a given point now is
inside a hole okay because of conforming
variants this probability does not
depend on the actual point you're
looking at so first remark and the
second remark is of course that you know
if imagine now I take my scissors and I
cut I cut something out here right maybe
if you're lucky by cutting this out you
are actually you know meeting a hole
that surrounds this point and then you
discover that this point is inside a
hole if you're not lucky right
so either you win and you're in a hole
and if you're not lucky
well you didn't find something but that
means that this guy is this point is
somewhere sitting inside one of the
pieces of the sponsor you've cut away
and what's the probability now that this
point is in a hole well is still the
same as
the one you started with okay so what
you see is either you win or you're
allowed to play again the same game
right because then you can see you know
in my remaining picture is this point in
a hole or not well so if you are if you
win or you're allowed to play again then
eventually you will win so that means at
this point every at this point here the
probability that it sits inside the hole
is one okay so this simple argument
tells you that every each given point
has a probability one of being in a hole
and this little argument just tells you
you know well that tells that if you
interchange the in you can integrate
over all the points the probability that
it's in a hole this will tell you that
almost surely with probability one the
lebesgue measure of the set of points
that are in holes is one in other words
if you have these random structures they
are fractal so the these compact sets
that you have here right there will be
typically they must they will have to be
a fractal nature where basically the
lebesgue measure random fractals where
the lebesgue measure of the holes is 1
but nevertheless it doesn't you know it
doesn't contradict the fact that this
guy here could be connected this random
spawn which would be connected so the
idea you have in mind now you know is
that if you have something like that it
should be some random randomized version
of structures that are reminiscent
either of the serpents ki carpet right
which is one of those guys where you
know the lebesgue measure of this of the
holes is actually full or well you know
a gasket where you remove the holes and
the holes would actually sort of touch
the boundary and you would have
something like that so it looks like the
shape of the holes will be random but
the idea will be that these conformal
loopholes or more or these randoms
they would have to be you know random
fractals of a certain type if they
existed of course the first reaction is
say well this is just way too strong a
condition these objects like that cannot
exist on the other hand if you think of
you know random systems coming from
physics and you try to view these you
view these holes as boundaries of
interfaces for a nearest neighbor
interaction model then immediately you
see well these you know systems coming
from physics they should satisfy this
type of property provided they are they
are conformally invariant okay so now
any question about the definition and
first properties of these object so now
there's a you know first theorem I want
to mention which is due to I mean they
are sort of several layers but one of
the main players in this story is
Sheffield then we have this long paper
together on this topic and there are
also important contribution by Miller
Sheffield and Sheffield and where you
can sum up this by saying well there are
only there's you know the collection of
possible random sponges like this is the
one dimensional you have one parameter
you can play it one real parameter as we
like to call Kappa and for each value of
Kappa you have one random distribution
run random picture that you can define
like that and you have no other ways
right so we know all possible random
sponges
and it's a one-parameter family and for
historical reasons it's indexed by a
number kappa that belongs to a 3rd and
8th
somehow the limit when going to a 3rd
and 8th is somehow a third will be the
random sponge which is actually full you
could take the random pictures that
there's nothing to see so you cut it
open there's still nothing to see you
put it back you have the entire disk it
would be one limiting case and the other
kid in the other direction would be
somehow that you know it's empty but
okay it's indexed by by kappa and you
have to type of and you will app you
know then comes you know some numerology
you know funny things that tells you
that i mean there are two type of
sponges so yeah the those that are
gaskets right where somehow the the
holes don't touch never touch each other
and never touch the outer boundary and
this would correspond to the value kappa
between a third and four and for the
gaskets so the idea would be that you
have a picture like that and then you
have all these holes and it has of
course this you know a sure hyperbolic
type feeling that you know you have you
know here you have plenty of small holes
and what you know and that's the sort of
the numerology type thing that if I
choose the random gasket correspond to
this value of Kappa then we know what
the fractal dimension of the boundary of
the holes is it's going to be 1 plus
Kappa over 8 and we know that what the
dimension of the of the sponge actually
is yes
I'll come back to that but of course we
okay so somehow the value of Kappa I
haven't L told you you know what Kappa
means so at this point I don't prefer to
oh sorry
yeah that's a carpet sorry the important
feature is that yeah I always get it
wrong it's not much better in French
because in French it would be Tammy and
Tapie and and again you are you always
get it wrong as well so it worse anyway
so this is the carpet sorry right this
is the one where the holes don't touch
each other and the dimension of this guy
if I remember it correctly is one plus
two over Kappa plus I mean this you know
something like that not quite sure about
the formula the dimension okay that's
not magic numerology that you can you
know fine I mean the fun part is somehow
that this tells you that for instance
the dimension of the boundaries of these
holes which you look at you know the the
carpets it will vary it will be allowed
to vary between four thirds and three
halves but it can't be smaller than four
thirds it can't be larger than three
halves
if you unless you you are not going to
become you know you have these sort of
strange features and you see that I mean
if you if you look at the definition
looks like you know abstract nonsense
definition very simple conditions and
then you end up with some you know
strange features and and again you know
the dimension of the carpet if I didn't
get it wrong indeed when you get 8/3
prob I think you should get to and when
you go down to Kappa equal four you get
something like 15 over 8 right though
this the smallest possible gasket has a
certain fractal dimension 15 over 8 and
you have the gaskets they would
correspond to Kappa larger than four and
they have the same formula right so the
picture there would be more like the
holes each hole is touching the boundary
at a fractal set of points and then you
have a picture a bit like that so
reminiscent of the sierpinski gasket
except that you don't touch the boundary
at three points but you sort of touches
the boundary on the fractal okay and of
course if you know Kappa if you've heard
you know oded or anybody talking about
SLE you remember that we lied to
parameterize sles by a parameter cations
it's the same Kappa so in some sense
these boundaries here will be will be
one of those SLE type curves or
basically loops so just for you know
little motivation Kappa equals four
special obviously it's special in the
sense that it comes up very naturally in
this initial question I gave you when I
said you know what's the natural
oscillation away from the riemann from
the euclidean distance in two dimension
you try to see what is there way you
know to make the wiggle of the distance
between points in a natural way in a
random way and what comes out of the
picture is sort of this fairly you know
of course I'm sort of a bit I just want
to stimulate your imagination more than
you know saying concrete results here
but what comes out roughly speaking is
that the natural structure that emerges
will be that the the space will sort of
you will have sort of fracture lines so
the sort of the idea will be that the
metric if whatever that means you know
will have there will be sort of lines
along which on one side everything looks
a bit larger than on the other side
right and these things you know somehow
they it's not like the perturbation of
the metric will be something super
it will be something you know we sort of
jumps and sort of fracture lines and and
these type of whole structure that we
have here are exactly the way that you
know these things will I mean how this
happens now for capital now I want to so
that's one story and I hope I presented
it to you in a way that you could see
that well that you know the the the the
question is natural somehow and somehow
the answers are non-trivial and of
course I didn't tell you any thing about
how to prove this this is a long story
right you have a couple of hundred pages
T to swallow before seeing how the proof
goes but now I want to say tell you
another story and the other story is is
the following so here what we have our
random fractal structures and they are
naturally related to conformity variance
and so my first I want to tell you two
stories before actually try to go to the
domain result I want you to explain and
of course given time I will not have
time to give you many more details
either the first idea is sort of the the
idea you know I'm going back to Odette
France Italy and let me try to present
it in a abstract way that is reminiscent
of what I did here I have a simply
connected domain and I want to do an
experiment that is conformer invariant
right so that somehow and my experiment
is to use scissors I want to cut this
domain open in a random way right I want
to you know take my scissors and cut it
open
and I want two things the first thing
would be that the way I do it is
conformally invariant so in the sense
that I start cutting this open should be
more or less invariant on the group of
Mobius transformations of course you
need to know where you start right and
more or less where you go but I'll come
back to that in a moment and the other
thing what you want to do is the
following is that if I start cutting
open I reach this now
well you just use Riemann's mapping
theorem sort of two uniform eyes this
slip domain into the original domain
right so the red part now is somewhere
has been you know mapped down so you cut
it open you map back and what you remain
what you have to do now is to cut open
starting from the image of this point so
here what we do is say imagine we take
four when you have a slit domain here
gamma t you define f t gamma t starts
from zero you define F T to be the
conformal transformation from the domain
minus gamma up to 20 and to see and
you're going to map F of gamma T back to
zero and you're going to say F G at
infinity will be like Z right so this
characterizes your conformal
transformation F T and what you want
right the condition is something bit
something like similar there if I cut up
to a certain time T you stop you go out
you have coffee break and now we say
okay coming back I need to continue
cutting how am I going to cut continue
cutting well the way I'm going to
continue to cut is exactly as if I first
map this back and I do the same
experiment again starting from here
right so the law of the picture of what
remains to be done is always the same
you're always sitting on the boundary of
a simply connected domain and you cut
into it and you always do the same
modulo conformal transformations
okay so there's a you know very simple
remark which is that if you parameterize
time here in some sense by the size seen
from infinity of what you are cutting
your way you can there exists this you
know the this expansion your it in
infinity you can write it like Z plus
something that you could call WT which
would be sort of the real constant shift
term that you get here plus something
that you can choose to be to increase
linearly plus little or 1 over Z right
so this is just a way to decide how to
parameterize this growing slit this
condition that what remains to be done
is just the copy of what I started with
means that you know if you compose two
independent guys like that you should
get exactly the guy up to time 2t you
know I cut open and my back I cut open
and my back it's the same as if I would
cut open all the way without break and
so this tells you immediately that this
T gives WT has to be basically a
Brownian motion no chance you know
that's just the way it is because it's
sort of additive you know adding WT plus
an independent company of WT you will
have to have basically the guy up to
time to T so this tells you this guy has
to be Brownian motion and then you read
you know I'll force and you know or you
learned about Livni's equation and you
say well but actually the knowledge of
this function T gives WT characterizes
the whole sequence ft and it
characterizes gamma ok so basically this
is Schramm's idea that says well you
know if i want to have a random curve
that cuts its open i have only one
parameter family of guys that is
basically I have to choose WT to be a
Brownian motion running at a certain
speed chuckle kappa so WT is this real
guy you know that measures you know
if this guy it goes more to the left or
to the right scene from infinity or up
this and this one has to be drum okay
now there's an additional condition that
I want to emphasize which is that if you
are looking for a random procedure right
where infinity doesn't actually play a
special role that when I start cutting
it should be invariant under the Mobius
transformation that in you know sends
infinity to one I mean keep zero fixed
and 30 to 1 and minus 1 to infinity
right so you start pushing it like that
and you want that the way you stop
cutting is actually the same random way
starting from zero then you see that
there's just one kappa such that somehow
this cutting procedure is independent of
infinity somehow well the choice where
the other boundary thing is kappa i
equals 6 so there's a special way of
cutting open the domain right yeah
that's the idea i have here just one
point here i give you just information
where you start cutting and you know you
could target this point that points this
other point it doesn't matter there's
just one random way to start cutting
open this thing in in this that
satisfies this property here and the
fact that the law of this orange curve
is the same if infinity is here or is
infinity is there so it's sort of really
growing locally okay and this is the
sort of Schramm's idea that said yeah
well cap i equals 6 has to be the
scaling limit of critical percolation
interfaces because these are the models
in statistical physics that have this
locality this sort of local property ok
so we have this special random curve and
that's the I mean this is a curve with
dimension ok 7/4 and ok that's
interesting
now we have other so that's one story
now the other story is saying now this
idea which the idea is to say that this
red curve is a random way to explore
random way to explore this domain that's
simply connected you remain you have in
front of you right you have this disk
and you have this random you know of
this you want to cut open you want to
sort of discover it and you discover it
completely at random by cutting you know
cutting open at random uniformly in some
sense is giving you this random curve
here that you could characterize you
know very simply using lewdness
formulism so now the question is what
can one do when you try to explore you
know this fractal domain here we want to
do something similar which is we want to
discover fractal domains so let me now
take a second background story that's a
complimentary yolk of this exploration
story there imagine I have any fractal
domain so you could say let's take the
sierpinski carpet now when you're doing
complex analysis you read I don't know
Cooper's uniformization theorem say okay
you know we it's nice to do complex
analysis when you have holes it's
actually fun and what happens when the
you know the number of holes goes to
infinity and when you have a guy like
that which is actually not an open set
anymore but it's actually a fractal oh
is zero lebesgue measure what remains
you know what
is there still complex analysis living
inside this fractal and the answer is
yes okay there are different ways to
approach this if you are
coming you know from Alpha cuber
you know vision you want to say well is
there a uniformization theorem that says
is there a natural you need you need a
way to uniform eyes the sierpinski
carpet and the answer is yes and you
probably heard more your bank explained
you that in some sense there's a unique
transformation that you know maps this
sierpinski carpet carpet into a circle
circular fractal carpet right something
like that that's one way to try to
approach it but that tells you already
you know when I have fractals actually
there is conformal structure sitting
inside the fractals even though I can
always distort the holes as I want you
know the holes are really holes they are
sitting out there outside my tent
there's a second thing you can do is to
say well laplacian right you want to
define some sort of a laplacian sitting
in there or alternatively is there a
Brownian motion in the carpet is there
something like the Brownian motion that
would live inside this carpet and again
you have the sequence of papers in the
90s by Chris Bertie and rich I mean bas
who proved that indeed you can make
sense of what Brownian motion would be
in this fractal of course it's tricky
right because the if you want to move
around and this fractal you have these
obstacles you know in front of you
everywhere they are blocking you so the
Brownian motion here would have a very
non diffusive behavior right it will
have to to get at each scale you are
blocked by things that large so you have
to sort of do some something with the
clock of the Brownian motion and and for
those of you who know Mario's paper sort
of there are striking similarities
between you know the two approaches the
approaches basically say
well you know let's let's first look at
what happens when you have only finitely
many also you can do apply Cuba's
uniformization theorem annual say well
because we add the holes everywhere more
or less in a self-similar way things
will stabilize and the Brownian motion
has a similar picture that you know you
understand the Brownian motion when
you're finitely many holes and then when
you have more and more holes because of
the exact self-similarity structure the
the you know the Brownian motions from
how and the finitely connected domain
will converge to the Brownian motion
perfectly new well speeded up will
converge to the Brownian motion in the
in the farm ok that's one way to probe
some of Conformity variance but of
course you might say I mean you one
might wonder how you know relevant the
Brownian motion that moves in this and
this object actually is that's one thing
and one might wonder you know how you
know how robust these general features
and now I want to explain a third way to
you know to use conforming variance
which is this one here right which is
you know how to cut open in a conforming
variant way somehow the this structure
that you are here so and maybe I just
you know say two words the the first
thing is that this structure are defined
to you now I'm questioning to spend five
minutes saying little statistical
physics story but in a very elementary
way I'm not statical physics from a
simple mobile picture one way to
understand what is unique green curve
here is is to say that roughly speaking
your coloring at random the plane in
with two colors
so maybe the good idea would be to say
you take an exact neural lattice
honeycomb lattice and each cell will be
toss the coin to decide whether it's
orange or green and then what you're
doing is you know you're coloring the
boundary one half of the boundary in
green one half of the boundary in orange
and this slicing open that you have
there will be exactly the random curve
that you see by you know exploring the
interface between the green cluster
attached to the green boundary and the
orange cluster attached to the orange
boundary and conforming variants right
across you know when you start cutting
open with your scissors that have green
on the lower right and orange on the
left we are just exploring this boundary
well now you have cut it open you
haven't discovered this state of the
coloring that remains to be discovered
there and you have a domain where on the
boundary here everything is green and on
this one boundary everything is orange
and therefore it's sort of the if the
limit of this curve here when the mesh
of the lattice goes to zero is
conforming variant and the limit it
should be the one I described there
because it will have this little you
know
combination of conforming variants
slicing open and and and locality
property so what happens when you color
the sierpinski carpet at random so here
the idea would be to say let's take all
the clusters to be green the holes the
clusters are green and now you colored
random orange or green the remaining
part well I mean clearly green will win
because you compare to the previous
picture you have all these holes that
are everywhere so Green will will win
but if a microscopic level you give an
advantage to orange you say well on the
small scale the heck
the orange guy will have probability
three quarters to be there and the
greens one will have to have property
one quarter to be there and you think
about it and then what you realize is
that if you tune your microscopic model
conveniently then you will be able to
have macroscopic orange clusters that
are infiltrating inside the fractal so
you will have map you know orange paths
you know that all sort of fiddling their
way within the fractal and there will be
a phase transition and there will be you
know a parameter where you can make
sense of what what is now the sort of
exploration of this fractal you know
what's the outer boundary of the orange
cluster attaching the orange boundary
inside this fractal okay so so the idea
was each time you bump into a hole right
then the hole is green so it's on your
right so you have to you know you have
to go around it like this however is
sort of the pressure the orange pressure
is sort of infinite but well tuned so
that actually you are able to make it
through inside this little piece okay so
question is you know can we describe the
this continuum structure this continuum
curve right that should be play the role
of these chicks in this fractal
what we have in our hands is conforming
variants we would expect that again
something like that would respectful for
me variance but we are in a very bad
shape because something goes completely
wrong when we try to adapt this which is
when you start cutting this open you
want to cut it back to uniform eyes this
bar remains mapping theorem
everything was fine there because we are
the you know simply connected domain you
map it back you're back in there simply
connected domain but here of course when
you cut open your map back you know all
the relative positions and sizes of the
holes have moved so you have to keep
tracks and have infinitely many
parameters you know to keep track of the
actual conformal structure of the
remaining to be discovered domain right
because when you slice open
or you know all these all these holes
will move and jump around so this seems
that there's a obstruction here that
tells me well that we're not going to be
make this able to make this work here in
this picture however if you think about
it my the message is and this is that
actually it is possible to make it work
if the fractal you're looking at is not
a see Pinsky carpet or a deterministic
one but if the fractal itself is the one
that nature really produced right so
what I what I want to emphasize you know
that's a very program pocket of
statements but it's sort of saying that
the random sponges I described to you at
the beginning they are the fractals then
actually you find you know around you
there are the ones that you know when I
was a child and you know I was I had the
the rusty or no car that we have
everybody had in France and was rusty it
has the rusty hole and you know you
learn you know don't touch the rusty
hole you're going to cut your finger
because it's okay that's because it's
and then you say because you're a smart
little child here yeah because it's
fractal so it's like you know the
boundaries fractal so therefore it's
like a knife and I'm going to cut my
finger so anyway didn't work the the
shape of the hole is actually one of
these random things right one of these
random holes that I've sort of described
of course it's not true but anyway you
know just this idea that we don't really
see you know the sierpinski carpet you
know in real life you know it's it's
pretty tough to actually find it you
know produced by some on its own by in
nature around you whereas these other
guys you know it's it's not just what
I'm saying is it's not just saying well
oh let's do something you know fun let's
try to do this play this game in these
special fractals we define which are
themselves random and see
happens well but it sort of blazes sort
of some motivation to do that because
these fractals are not they are actually
the ones that you see around in in
physical system phase transitions or
whatever now now the thing is the
following you do this usual trick that
we like to use in the propolis like to
use quenched and annealed when they try
to describe this but I don't want to use
this there I just say well I cut this
open right in front of me I have this
random fractal where these fractal
random holes sitting there I don't know
yet where they are I cut open the all
the holes are green right so I cut this
open and when I meet a hole right it's
green I discover it you know when I bump
into a hole well I discover the entire
hole and I know I need to continue
exploring when I do this the rule I gave
you about you know cutting open slicing
open my domain the rule was I have my
fractal carpet here and I cut open in a
deterministic way what remains to be
discovered you know is the the holes
that I have not discovered yet are
distributed like the holes that in in
the remaining to be discovered the main
provided that each time I bump into hole
I cut out the entire you know it's like
a puncture then you discover the entire
hole at once once you bump into it with
your scissors now you could do that by
you know I have I'm sitting here on the
boundary and I cut very carefully a
little slit infinitesimal slit I told
you we are going to discover immediately
little holes because every given point
will be inside also even if you be very
careful you immediately discover you
know holes but still what you will
discover will be small and then you can
decide well you know now I continue
cutting depending on what I have you
know I can iterate this procedure
because what remains to be discovered
has the same distribution as what I
started with and you can sort of adapt
where you're continuing to cut depending
on the holes that you have discovered so
far right
by iterating the initial thing by you
cup very carefully a little bit discover
what I have and now I'm going to cut
here to the right or to the left
depending on what I have already defined
you're going to be able to mimic this
thing that you know you cut open a
little bit I discover a hole then you
know I have to continue going around in
this direction I'm going to cut here and
if you do this very carefully right this
thing you'll have the property that I
start cutting open I want to define a
random care of gamma that has the
following property that conditionally of
the care of gamma and I attached all the
holes that it has the property that each
time I bump into a hole I have to go
turn left right because the hole is
green I'm looking my interface orange on
the right green on the on the right
orange on the left green on the left
anyway right so each time I bump the
rule is each time I bump into the hole
the hole is on my right and when I stop
I make a coffee break I come back what
remains to be discovered right I'm
sitting here my boundary is orange here
green on the other side the law of what
remains to be done is what is the
conformal image of the law what I
started with and here you're using the
fact that they're not yet discovered
holes are distributed exactly as long as
you haven't discovered them they are not
there and so therefore the law of the
remaining to be discovered fractal
domain is always distributed like the
one you started with so in some sense
you re average after each time you re a
ver egde about you know the conformal
structure of the remaining to be
discovered domain you don't need to keep
track of your in your bag you know about
the relative positions of all the holes
that you have in front of you right
because you could say well I don't know
where they are so there will be
distributed like the initial
distribution because I have one of these
very special fractal domains where the
distribution of the holes that remain to
be
is actually always the same in the
remaining to be discovered domain
modular conforming varies so what you
get here is that so you see here I'm
just saying the following what we are
after here is something where we want a
procedure to cut open in an adaptive way
our domain that's what we're after in
such a way that it's local you know I
cut open
each time I bump into a hole I turn to
my left to the left and it's local
as long as I've don't bump into the you
know holes arrive in front of you I
don't this will not influence me and of
course always you know re a ver egde
about the distribution of the remaining
to be discovered holes so the theorem is
and of course in a not being very
precise so this is this paper we're
writing now with Jason Sheffield and
chip field this is one way to present
the result there are sort of other ways
to approach it which is to say well we
know what is random tourism right so we
know what the role of the of course
unique local and conformally invariant
way to cut open a random sponge is
so what happens is that I have my sponge
here my random sponge which is here it
has this fractal dimension you know
given by this value of Kappa and what
happens is that the curve that you're
going to describe here that is the
unique random curve that somehow is the
analog of s le6
here the unique percolation you know
what would be the natural random curve
that you could view as continuous
percolation inside boundary inside my
fractal that you can really just view as
you know the unique way natural way to
cut open my domain in the learner way in
a random you know lunar equation type
way in my fractal domain and it turns
out that actually this curve there's a
duality type property that shows up that
this curve that you define here is
exactly going around the fractal gasket
I mean so each gasket is associated at
carpet
and what happens somehow is that by
moving around here those sort of you you
get the I mean there's a sort of duality
that tells you that to each random
carpet is associated a random gasket and
that somehow these this percolation
interface is actually sort of yeah okay
maybe anyway we know what it is and it
has dimension sort of the interface for
instance has dimension is I mean this
random curve is an SLE of dimension 16
over Kappa which should not surprise you
for those of you who know the duality
between FK marbles and pot small walls
or any way but there's a natural
structure that says that somehow this
this curve here what happens is that
this curves you go inside
right and each time I see a hole and
somehow go around the hole and they
continue like that so it's a little bit
like what you're discovering is somehow
a little bit like you know a structure
with you know a tree with the leaves
they're not only on one side and the
trunk of this tree somehow is this
circulation interface except that the
trunk is actually curved that bounces on
itself as well
it's a quiet convoluted curve but we can
sort of describe it and so again you
know you can you know sell we could one
can try to sell this result to you you
know people who are not coming from
circus I mean from statistical physics
or not interested in the theoretical
physics in the play by saying well you
know there's a unique random curve
sitting in each of these fractals random
fractals that have the property that
it's actually you know when you slide it
open you map it back you get this new
structure there now this works only for
Kappa smaller than four for Kappa / 4
there's no there's no way to infiltrate
what happens is that the the the fractal
somehow is even though it's dimension
doesn't nothing special happens to this
dimension goes to 16 what happens is
that at Kappa equal 4 the the this
carpet is of a very different type
roughly speaking when Kappa is equal to
4 what about strictly smaller than 4 the
carpet is a bit like the sierpinski
carpet right so the holes are you know
away from each other fairly separated
and at scale they're separated this
similar scale when Kappa is equal to 4
the holes are larger and then
occasionally you will find holes are
very close to each other big holes that
are close to each other and then the you
know it's they this problem this will be
the main problem that the percolation
that this you know orange guy will have
to circumvent will have to you know I
have to go through these tiny holes and
something goes wrong so the only way to
do is to
you know you put more pressure you put
more pressure more more orange more ah
yes so you don't make it you're blocked
by these holes and as soon as you able
to make it through these you know these
little things then you actually made
everything all right so this is the
nature of the face percolation phase
transition within this yearly fall
carpet is actually a very different
nature then now there's one additional
thing so what the the final comment I
want to make is here one understands in
these random sponges one understands
what you know learner SRAM is doing
right so how to cut open how to Mack
back and how to you know cut open
randomly in a conformally invariant way
so again that means that these random
curves they use in a very intrinsic way
something that has to do with the
conformal structure sitting in the hole
in this carpet itself it uses its a
random object it uses no information
about you know the holes it's invariant
under any conformal transformation of
your domain into itself you know that
preserves the rules so if you are tell
you know you can distort this decide
that this whole bow is aligned or
whatever the the random thing you define
there is actually still consorted this
conformal invariance property so using
really something having to do with the
essential conformal structures sitting
in the holes and this is one thing you
know this is one interesting feature now
I want to emphasize defin and Brent
Scheffel rule and Brent Verna's there
are understand about finalized write-up
of the fact that for those carpets here
you can adapt in a certain way Mario
bonks ideas because I told you these
fractals when Kappa strictly smaller
than four they are randomized versions
of the sierpinski carpet but still
things are under control and they are so
much under control that you can actually
adapt Mari that they are able to adapt
Mario's paper to say that there is a
unique there's a uniformization theorem
for these carpets
right so that somehow there's these
random carpets have a unique you know
circle domain I mean up to maybe this
transformation unique in a circle domain
version equivalent version so which is
also a way to describe the you know the
intrinsic fractal structure is that
correct this takers correct
okay okay okay but they are able to
uniform eyes it okay but that's an you
know we're not able to define at this
point nobody is able to define the
Brownian motion in this object and the
question is whether it's worth the
effort because you know well you have to
control things I mean of course you
might say we know of course you know
what you want to do you might say well I
just keep the largest holes I take the
Brownian motions as is bouncing on the
on the boundaries and then you know I
put more and more holes I have to fiddle
with my clock so that indeed you know
things didn't blow up and when the
number of holes you know there are more
and more holes things should be under
control and this guy should converge to
something but we don't know how to do
this and for those of you who know the
bass ball Oh
papers already in the sea Penske carpets
it's a total nightmare to actually you
know control it even in the case where
things are deterministic so it's hard to
it's really tricky also I want to
emphasize two things one thing is that
here when you say there's the conformal
structure here each in each of these
questions you are actually probing
different things in the sense that maybe
some of you have heard about you know
uveal Brownian motion in Galston free
field things are like that here somehow
when you do this percolation inside the
fractal what happens is that all the
information somehow in the all the
randomness sitting in the fractal will
be located at special points in the
fractals that are going to be very
important in order to decide if the
interface is going right or left I
already mentioned that in the case of
these very small tubules here that
somehow these are you know when the
there will be some points sitting in the
fractal that I'm where it's
more important to know if this point is
green or orange than others and so the
idea is that there will be those of a
fractal you know like a bit like in a
multi fractal spectrum type ideas there
will be some the information will be
sitting in a special fractal subset of
this domain for percolation where as
saying for uniformization or for
Brownian motion the information might
sit actually elsewhere or a bit
elsewhere so you know you are probing in
these fractal things somehow you know
things are not smooth and though which
were is actually the information about
the conformer invariance structure that
you're looking at is actually sitting
might depend on the question you ask to
your fractal so typically there is no
relation about the fractal dimension of
the carpet itself right there's no oh
yes I'm overtime sorry yeah it
there's no somehow you know the
dimension of the fractal itself has
nothing to do with you know what happens
in terms of population because the
percolation structure will be actually
sitting in actually a fractal subset of
the carpet itself so there's sort of
this sort of averaging type thing going
on okay I'm over time I'm getting thrown
bottles at my yeah so I have to
certainly stop and also I want to say
that as the last speaker of coal sights
my great pleasure to behalf of all
speakers to thank again our organizers
for setting up everything so smoothly
and it's you know for those of you or us
who organized conferences like that you
very well know that the more smoothly it
is for you that means that the more you
know last-minute and tricky things have
to been handled by someone so I
understand that Karen has been the main
person in charge of it and with a big
smile saying that she's there so to make
sure everything is fine for us but and
indeed so I just want to thank again
everyone in all of you for sticking to
the end of the last talk before catching
your train now thank you